قال عضو مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي بيني جانس
انه مستمر في عمله في الحكومه ما دامت
هناك حاجه لذلك جانس اكد في مؤتمر صحفي
انه لن يكون درعا واقيا
لاحد اننا ننوي البقاء في الحكومه ما دامت
هناك حاجه الينا انا خادم لشعب اسرائيل
وعندما يكون باستطاعتي ان اؤثر في الاوضاع
لن اتردد في فعل
ذلك كما اكد عضو مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
بيني جانس ان العمليات العسكريه في غزه لن
تتوقف حتى تحقق اهدافها النهائيه وقال ان
انجازات الجيش الاسرائيلي اخذه في
الازدياد انه لم تعد لحماس سلطه في جزء
كبير من قطاع
غزه يجب ان نواصل عملينا العسكريه اذا
توقفنا ستعود حماس اننا ملتزمون بالاهداف
البعيده التي حددناها اعاده المختطفين
احياء وازاله تهديد حماس الواقع يلزمنا
بذلك في معظم المناطق اكملنا السيطره
العسكريه ونحن في عمق البنى الارهابيه
وسنصل في النهايه الى تفكيك قدرات
حماس